there's power in games
yeah and you've recently gotten into uh
recently i'm not sure you can correct me
uh mechanism design yeah uh
so it's i mean first of all maybe you
can explain what mechanism design is and
the the fascinating space of playing
with games
and designing games mechanism design is
that
you want to you want a certain behavior
to arise right if you want to organize
you know
a societal structure or something you
want to have some orderly
behavior to our eyes right because uh it
is important for
your goals but
you know that people they don't care
what my goals are
makers about uh maximizing their utility
so put the grassley making money the
more money
the better so to speak right i'm
exaggerating
self-interest in what self-interest in
whatever way then so what you want to do
is um ideally what you want to do is to
design a game so that while people
played so to maximize their
self-interest
they achieve the social goal and
behavior that i want
that is really the best type of thing
and it is a very
hard science and art to design with
games and it challenges us
to
actually come up with solution concepts
for way to analyzing the games
that need to be broader and i think
phenomenal game theory is a developing a
bunch of very compelling
way to analyze the game that if the game
has a best property
well you can have a pretty good
guarantee that is going to be played in
a given way
but as it turns out and not surprisingly
these tools have a range of action like
anything else all these
so-called the technical resolution
concept the way to analyze the game like
dominant strategy equilibrium if
something comes to mind to be
very meaningful but as a limited power
in some sense the games that they can be
admit such a way to be analyzed there's
a very specific kind of games and the
the rules are set the constraints are
set the utilities are all set
yes so if you want to reason if there is
a way
say that you can analyze
a restricted class of games this way but
most games you know don't fall into the
rest of the class then what do i do
when you need to enlarge
a way what a rational player can do
so for instance uh in my opinion at
least in some of my
i played with this for a few years and i
i was doing some exothermic things i'm
sure
in in the in the space that was not
exactly mainstream
and then i changed my interest and i
would do blockchain
but what i'm saying for a while i was
doing so
for instance to me is a way in which i
design the game
and you don't have the best move for you
the best move is the move that is best
for you no matter what the other players
are doing
sometimes a game doesn't have that okay
it's too much to ask
but i can design the game such of it
given the option in front of you say oh
these are really stupid for me take them
aside
but these these are not stupid so if you
design them
the game solve it in any combination or
non stupid things that the player can do
i achieve what i want i'm done i don't
care
to find the very unique equilibrium
i i don't give a damn i want to say well
as long as you don't do stupid things
and nobody else does stupid things good
social things
outcome arise i should be equally happy
and so i really believe that um
this type of analysis you know is
as possible and uh as a bigger
uh radius so he reaches some more
games more classes of games and uh and
after that we had to enlarge it again
and uh and it's going to be we're going
to have fun
because uh human behavior can be
conceptualized
again in many ways and is it's a long
game
you